i would like for you all to be very
important and special
new member of our family
guess what today is everybody scott what
day is it
uh scott's new iphone day scott's new
iphone day
indeed note that it's scott's new iphone
day
and not our new iphone day
where i woke up at 4 30 a.m last week
because the iphone pre-order
was at 5 00 am scott this guy didn't
wake up
i ordered my iphone through apple.com
but i had technical difficulties
ordering his so ordered his on verizon
who is our
mole carrier and uh his came
a week before my mind doesn't come till
next week what did you get
i told you
you're welcome
it's the box is so much thinner this
year
it's because they don't have like the
charging block anymore
oh my goodness we both got the iphone
12 pro in white what do you think scott
i like it
i like that they went back to this kind
of iphone 4s
style
[Music]
corner what do you think of your iphone
[Music]
you don't care that much what if i made
another app for you bud
no you don't want it here you go
it's what all the kids are using
nowadays talk to their friends
good morning everyone it's monday
morning and guess what we getting a dog
scotty we're getting a dog maybe maybe
maybe
it's like 95 sure we're getting a dog
we submitted an application for a dog
that we saw on pet finder
last night and a lot of dog rescues
these days
are expecting like three to seven day
turnaround
times for applications because the
volunteers
are typically very slammed because of
cobin and everyone in san diego wants a
dog
so that's what i said in the application
yesterday we'll get back to you within
three to seven days
but i submitted it last night at like 9
00 p.m
got a text at 9 9am asking
about us and whether we'd be down to
to meet her it's happening it's
happening we've been looking for a dog
for like maybe a month or so we've
actually submitted two other
applications but they didn't work out
i'm pretty excited about this one my day
has just and my month and my week has
completely changed from what i thought
it would be
hey welcome home welcome home that's
your big brother
first meal together
so today i would like for you all to
meet a very
important and special new member of our
family
it's ellie oh
oh you're so sleepy right now this is
ellie
who is the latest member and newest
member of our household
she's sleeping right now but she's super
cute
she is a six month probably beagle mix
she's from tijuana in mexico she's a
distemper survivor
so distemper is a really terrible
disease
that happens in many many animals but
she had the canine distemper
dogs die from it it's got like a 95
mortality rate
but she survived so she's a little
miracle dog unfortunately
it's caused some nerve damage and so
she's got kind of this lifelong tick
where her muscles like her paws and her
shoulders jerk a little bit if you can
see that
it doesn't bother her we give her pain
medication
for it and she's able to sleep through
it it doesn't slow her down
she is a super sweet happy puppy
and we're really excited to give her a
home and she's just
so cute
good girl she's a rescue dog just like
kona and
i've been wanting a second dog for a
long time our goal was to have two dogs
now that we have our house and we're all
settled in we figured it was kind of the
right time to do so
[Music]
also she turns to liquid when she's
sleeping she just gets very limp
because she's in a deep sleep i'm just
gonna let her sleep while we're here
i also wanted to remind you of my new
merch
uh this is the code shirt it comes in
two colored t-shirts a hat as well as a
sticker
i'm really excited about this i've been
working on it for a long time and i'm
really excited that it's out
working with dftba which it's amazing
i've looked lively
looked up to the brand and hank and john
green forever so
unlike my previous merch supplier
they'll send to most countries so
a lot of y'all not living in the us
you're able to purchase this as well
so make sure to check that out in the
merch shelf down below as well as the
store link in the description box
so i want to talk to you all about
something uh that happened
last year um there's a kind of trigger
warning for
panic and anxiety and everything so
if that's all triggering for you which i
don't want it to be you can skip to this
time stamp below
i've mentioned it a couple times on
youtube videos and instagram posts and
stuff
but um the first week of november i
experienced a really terrible panic
attack
and then endured a really long anxiety
episode which basically kind of lasted
for an entire year like i still kind of
feel like i'm
in recovery from it basically i was
driving home from singing lessons one
day
last november and really sudden really
intense panic attack came
it just felt like it didn't stop and so
i ended up going to the er to make sure
that everything was
actually okay and it was but it really
threw me for a loop
my amygdala my brain was just like
everything is scary and there's a real
threat to your life
right now and you could be that threat
to yourself it was
a really really scary time i started
going to a new therapist that i had been
going to therapy but i went to go see a
new one
i went to go see a psychologist as well
got some medication
to manage my panic attacks as well it
was
really hard i think it's actually
probably one of the hardest things i've
ever done
the thing about mental health is that
it's you fighting your own brain
a lot of the times like for me it was
really frustrating because i was like
nothing is wrong in my life
everything is fine but my brain says
otherwise it's
really difficult to reason with your
brain in that moment
for me it was frankly terrifying for
someone who
wants to control things when things
aren't good and
everything's ambiguous over the last
year i've been learning a lot of
coping skills i've been a lot kinder to
myself i haven't been
judging myself that much i've been
taking more breaks i've been taking it
slower
i gotta say i feel so much better i
bring this up just because it's been on
my mind a lot
for the last couple of weeks as it
passed
the one year anniversary for that and
i've just been reviewing it and
reconsidering it
and i'm finally at a point where i'm
actually glad that i had the experience
as scary as it was and as weird as that
is to say
i'm really glad that i it took me for a
loop i was experiencing a lot of
change especially within my own career
like
this time last year was when i decided
to quit my job
and go full-time youtube that alone kind
of really did just send me for a trip
and i think there's a lot of other
things too at play yeah my brain really
just got into panic mode because it was
like yo
what the heck are you doing i am much
stronger now as a result because
i know how to manage my anxiety i know
how to interpret my feelings much better
i know how to
internalize my emotions without being
over
affected by them it took work y'all like
it took
so much work and patience and lots of
discomfort
it gets better honestly i listened to a
lot of dodie's
secret for the mad song which was so
reassuring at the time i mean this is
what anxiety does to your brain when
you're like it'll never get better
but it does and i do feel so much better
i had a lot of
changes in my life this last year and
maybe my brain knew that they were
coming and that's why
it threw that panic attack at me maybe
it knew that coven
or something terrible was gonna happen
and so it was like girl you gotta like
learn all this stuff now
so that we can get through this next
year i don't know
but i do feel a lot of gratitude for my
brain my body
my anxiety my experiences especially my
loved ones
who really really supported me through
that time oh my god i'm in a car just
thinking about it
oh god i wasn't gonna cry but i don't
know why it's there's emotions and you
know what it's not a bad thing to cry
it's not a bad thing
to be raw and let the tears out there's
no point in
extinguishing the flames that need to
burn you know
i feel very grateful that it's happened
because i've learned so much about
myself
and i've learned a lot about how to be
kinder to myself
and how to think about different things
how to be less judgmental
how to be less intense how to relax how
to be calm
how to be optimistic and have hope and
you know if any year was the year to
learn it was probably
this year been a lot of emotions and
it's actually been a little bit hard to
pick up the camera as a result but
i wanted to talk about it because i
thought it was important and it's just
through my mind
you know i want you all to know what's
going on
and i know a lot of y'all really truly
care
and i really super appreciate that so
thank you ah don't want to say cute
puppy let's go see the cute puppy again
because this stuff is heavy
oh look at the cute puppy she's so
cute i love her
oh my goodness i just gave ellie a bath
because she got peed on by kona
not because kona tried to pee on her but
because she went right underneath him
while he was peeing
and then she went outside and had
diarrhea which i had to pick up
this is just this is these are all the
tendence of taking care of a puppy
she's all good now i'm very glad she
didn't poop on the carpet
i think i deserve a little break if you
know what i mean
and i'm excited because i got my monthly
snack box delivered and i haven't opened
it yet and i'm excited to dive in
for those of you who don't know this is
baksu a monthly subscription service
that delivers japanese treats right to
your door
and they are the sponsor of today's
video every month there's a different
theme for the snacks
and various snacks from all over japan
get delivered
right to your door without you ever
needing to step foot into like an asian
market or anything
a lot of them are very seasonal which is
really fun because the flavors change
every month they ship to over 40
countries and it's a really convenient
way to have japanese snacks always
i've enjoyed every single one that i've
gotten so far and i like the variety in
them
some are savory and some are sweet and
some are full size others are tiny
and so you got like a really good mix of
a lot of stuff going on and because it's
the holidays
baksu is a wonderful gift to send to
someone you love i send it to my friend
who's all the way up in washington who
has
zero asian markets around her she's
japanese and so she
really really liked her box sue so i
suggest you do the same
i'm actually kind of dying to see what's
in here so let's just open this baby up
oh colors of kyoto they all come with a
culture guide by the way to tell you
all the allergens as well as the origins
of the different snacks so you don't
have to be able to read japanese to
enjoy these
wait this is kyoto
i'm from kansai this has got to be so
good
oh this looks this looks like money fam
it's a mochi mochi chocolate
so because you're the sponsor of this
video you can get 10 off your very own
boxy for a savings of up to 44
by using the link in the description box
down below or by using my code myuco10
not only do you get snacks delivered to
your door but by using that link it also
helps support my channel so
thanks thanks again to boxy for
sponsoring always
always a pleasure like literally just
like look at how soft
this looks like i want to eat it so bad
okay good evening fam it gets so
dark right after daylight savings ends
but
ella and i are just hanging out i i'm
actually upholstering some chairs
never done this before except i i did
try it last night
but i got these chairs on overstock
these ones they look super cool very
mid-century
matches the dining table which yes this
is the project that i was working on for
months
if you saw my instagram story i bought
this table off of
facebook marketplace it was really
pretty i liked the shape of it a lot but
the color
was just very orange it's made out of
pine
and pinewood tends to do that especially
if you put a coating on it called
polyurethane
which is what the previous owner did so
it was really orange but
i sanded it down i stained it i
refinished it and it's looking
it's looking really good so i wanted to
get some nice mid-century chairs to go
with it
so i got these which look great the wood
color is a little bit off but that
doesn't bother me
what does bother me is the seat itself
it's just a really kind of cheap looking
seat like just looking at it up close
it's not very high quality stuff and
it just doesn't really match even the
color of everything
i went to joann's the other adrian
fabrics and got a lot of
twill this is like upholstering twill
fabric
i got way too much of it and i
reupholstered this chair yesterday the
underside of it looks actually kind of
horrendous
yeah so it's just a bunch of staples
onto the chair with with this fabric
and i'm pretty proud of how it turned
out because there's no seams on it
and i think it looks much better than
the other one so yeah i'm
kind of just it's like eight o'clock
what better way to spend a dark
fall evening than to just upholster some
dining chairs
i don't know i think like i miss coding
a little bit and so i have this itch to
just like
make something like learn new things and
then make something with it and videos
are definitely one thing but i just
wanted to change things up
i feel like there's just a hole where
coding used to fill my heart
and now i'm feeling it to do things like
upholster furniture
but why not you know engineering mindset
you can fix everything on your own once
you
learn how to do it so let's try and do
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first one is done looks pretty good on
the front side huh
looks quite horrendous on my backside
real talk when i was in
high school my high school orchestra
used to host
like gift wrapping stations at the mall
every single christmas and winter
and so i got really really good at gift
wrapping because i did it every year and
the more hours you worked the more money
you got towards
your like funds to go to like disneyland
for that year or something
so i got really good at it and you know
actually
a lot of the like tricks that you use in
gift wrapping are exactly the same as
the ones you'd use in upholstering
so turns out doing community service
like that in high school
does have benefits more than just the
hours to graduate high school
so miss hall if you're watching thanks